good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-3729
object class
safe
special containment procedures
scp-3729 is to be kept in a standard
containment cell located in the safe
class containment center at site-26 any
testing with
scp-3729 must be conducted on d-class
subjects can be approved by the site
director site ethics committee
representative and site d-class resource
accountant all d-class used in these
experiments must
show no desire or ill will towards
anyone in the foundation
show no desire to commit any form of
crime
and have no history of cruel or unusual
behavior
for more information regarding what
constitutes cruel or unusual behavior
see ethics committee document 827b
d-class psychological profiles
description
scp-3729
is a wooden door frame consistent with
the 1910 kit home designs from the
american company's sears
scp-3729's anomalous effects manifest
when a human subject henceforth
scp-3729-1
walks through the doorframe the
anomalous effects exhibited by
scp-3729 will always affect the first
person to walk through it after sunrise
regardless of the number of individuals
which do so
scp-3729's first and most consistently
observed anomalous effect is that the
day after scp-3729-1
walked under
scp-3729 henceforth referred to in this
document as a24 for the sake of brevity
scp-3729-1 will wake up to the sunrise
regardless of whether or not the sun is
visible from their position and report
feeling remarkably well arrested
independent of how much sleep they
actually received all other anomalous
effects appear to be based on the
psychological profile of
scp-3729-1 and thus very considerably
scp-3729 has been shown to alter reality
in order to provide
scp-37291 what the subject would
consider an extremely pleasant
experience throughout a24 while the full
extent of
scp-3729's reality altering capabilities
is not known it has shown the ability to
edit foundation documents alter the
behavior and opinions of people
scp-3729-1 is aware of create matter and
affect results of games of chance
scp-3729 is likely capable of many more
effects but testing has been temporarily
suspended due to high financial cost and
lack of fitting d-class subjects
test one
test conducted by researcher ericsson
a24 date 11 16 2010 subject
d8375 male arrested for serial murder in
1994 had no psychological evaluation
prior to testing procedure
d8375 walked under scp-37
and was sent back to his holding cell
results at approximately 5 a.m on 11 16
2010 d 8375 was pardoned of his crimes
amnesticized given false memories and
released from foundation custody due to
a clerical error shortly after d8375 was
dropped on the outskirts of his hometown
he encountered mrs allison jacobson the
woman who made the police call that
resulted in d8375's arrest on vacation
on the morning after 11 16 2010 the
clerical error was discovered by d-class
resource accountant augustine mercy and
foundation personnel were sent to remedy
the situation mrs jacobson and
d8375 were found dead in an alleyway the
former due to choking and the latter via
self-inflicted blunt force trauma to the
head a crumpled note was found in
d8375's pockets which simply read i got
my revenge i ain't going back
notes the results of this test are
inexcusable researcher eriksen has
demonstrated extreme negligence and lack
of caution in his testing and has been
summarily demoted all further tests must
be preceded by the subject d-class
undergoing a thorough psychological
evaluation signed dr gonzalez site 26
ethics committee representative
test two
test conducted by researcher alphonse
a24 date 07 14 2012.
subject d2715
male
arrested for murder in 1993 has
expressed extreme regret over his
actions pre-experiment interviews
indicate that d-2715
strongly desired to quote to become a
world-renowned writer procedure see test
1 results at approximately 5 am on 07 14
2012
d2715 was pardoned of his crimes
amnesticized given false memories and
released from foundation custody due to
a clerical error
upon being dropped off on the outskirts
of his hometown
d-2715 located a winning powerball
lottery ticket on the ground near his
feet whereupon he approached the nearest
casino and cashed it in he then
proceeded to buy out all seats in wells
fargo stadium where his self-proclaimed
favorite band matchbox 20 was performing
he made the concert completely free and
provided full refunds to anyone who had
already bought tickets
d-2715 passed out seemingly from alcohol
poisoning at approximately 11 45 pm
shortly after waking up at 5 15 am
d2715 stumbled and fell off balcony 4d
of wells fargo stadium before foundation
personnel were able to retrieve him
notes
more thorough psychological evaluation
is required for these experiments all
future tests must include a polygraph
accompanied interview in order to
prevent false claims regarding the
stated desires of the d-class subject
this was an expensive mistake and it
best not happen again
signed dr gonzalez site 26 ethics
committee representative
test 3
tests conducted by researcher alphonse
a24 date 1008 2016 subject
d9762
female arrested for manslaughter in
1997. subject has shown extreme regret
over their actions and has expressed no
criminal desires after their arrest
polygraph accompanied interviews
indicate that
d-9762 possesses no ill will towards the
foundation these interviews also
indicated that d-9762
strongly desired quote a real meal one
with actual meat instead of that
[ __ ] they have at the cafeteria
procedure see test one
results
d9762 did not leave her holding cell a
clerical error resulted in all
d9762's scp assignments for the day
being voided patrol guard giovanni
mcconnell abandoned his post and
returned with a well done steak seasoned
with various spices which he handed to
d-9762
patrol guard giovanni mcconnell was
unable to explain where he obtained this
stake from as of writing
d-9762 remains alive and healthy
notes
d-9762's continued health is a notable
departure from the results of other
tests and should be kept in mind for
further testing signed researcher
alphonse
addendum
due to the extreme financial cost of
covering up the results of test 2 as
well as the difficulty in screening
d-class subjects for further experiments
testing with
scp-3729 has been temporarily halted
personnel requesting further tests must
first complete the standard foundation
testing renewal request form document
code b57 and submit it to the director
of site 26
archive document
found on the desk of researcher alphonse
standard foundation testing renewal
request form scp foundation secure
contain protect
submission date 12 16 2016
name researcher gerald alphonse
clearance level 3
item requested scp-3729
reason for requested testing renewal
to determine if through artificial
memory insertion and mental state
alteration techniques
scp-3729's reality altering capabilities
can be used to benefit the foundation's
containment goals
reply date 12 22 2016 this testing
request has been denied previously
accepted
reasoning
while
scp-3729 poses great possible value as a
thalmial class object the risks involved
in attempting to use it as such would be
far too great a single mistake could be
catastrophic and while it can on
occasion seem so memory insertion and
mental control are not perfect sciences
on a more personal note the goal of the
foundation is to serve and protect the
world not to control it and certainly
not to put it at pointless risk
you would do well to remember that
alphonse
signed
director of site-26
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargeran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
nicholas hayes
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
jaby
pure osmium
sayo diodemnatus
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbage
longinus
carcass death aqua
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you